[Music]
thanks for being here of course you are
uh of course uh obviously and
congratulations on your film too which
is doing great yeah yeah big head uh but
you know i'm serious you are uh a great
performer but you're also a very brave
man because uh we're talking about you
today and someone said that they read
recently that you you were at a concert
a prince concert and that you jumped on
stage while prince was jamming and
started dancing yeah and i thought i i
don't know anybody who's that brave well
anybody who could do that
what possessed you well you know i
started as a breakdancer before i was an
uh an actor as did i yes
that's right cheetah groom corner
i remember you used to spit on your head
i used to spin on my hair yes that's why
i grew this hair it's a great surface
it's a teflon surface exactly i don't
believe that okay
but
andy danced with me we were like kid and
play it was incredible yeah yes
well i mainly just carried the linoleum
[Laughter]
we were big in our day you just don't
remember that's a hell of an image but
you were you were uh yeah we were at the
concert and uh sheila he was sitting
behind me you know and he was actually
motioning for her to come up because i
guess he's part of her act yeah so i
took the opportunity to jump a blanket
i did so he was like okay come on up
prince is pointing at sheila e yeah
she's behind you you think here i go
prince wants me
and the funniest thing is she knew that
i was dancing so she was behind me thank
god doing this so he knew as i came up
all right come on up so what kind of
move were you doing break dancing moves
you're just kind of like you know
grooving the music man that's prince
yeah just getting it on yeah very nice
oh god i'm falling in love with you
right now
i have that effect
yes you do you know you were
[Applause]
you leave him alone he's mine
it's a mighty big microphone
yes it is
you uh you have a fine voice you you're
i didn't really you're your dad i i
remembered this uh your dad is an r b
singer that's right cuba gooding senior
yeah the lead singer the main ingredient
yeah which sings a great song everybody
plays a fool sometimes yeah
everybody plays pool
thank you andy
it may be factual maybe cruel yeah maybe
facts break dancers singers y'all
honorary black people
oh we know yes we know he's just like an
introverted shadowhunter keeper we get
that all the time
like a reverse oreo cookie
i like this you all want me to move
no no you're right there perfect where
you are this is fantastic i'm just
curious like when you're when you're a
kid is it and your dad has this hit song
yeah and he's this uh he's this star is
it kind of embarrassing when your dad's
famous like now if you know you you have
kids i know but i i'm always wondering
because i have kids i don't want my kids
to be embarrassed if people recognize
him anything did your dad call attention
to himself well my dad's a very
boisterous man you know he's got this
very voice so yeah his personality would
enter a room before he did yeah you know
i mean just anything about his you know
his voice i'm trying to i've been
bashing him lately in the press but he's
just you know one of them guys is like
that's my son
yes there it is
there he is
dad i just want to return this book
please
well you go ahead cause he can read the
book
all right
dad i'm 25.
yeah exactly
calm down yeah god has gotten even with
me because now my kids deal with the
show me the money thing a lot oh really
yeah so what happens if they go to
school while they're at school and you
know the kids are like you know like
they had a substitute teacher and she
said uh spencer getting and the kid said
that's to show me the money gooding of
dispencer goodings and
so i got to deal with that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
you know
very nice show me the grade
show me the
football show you the ass whooping in a
minute yeah yeah